pelouse grillée restrictions d'arrosage
et des bancs de sable qui grandissent
dans la loire serions nous en passe de
manquer d'eau au brgm les hydrogéologues
contrôler régulièrement le niveau de la
nappe de beauce la deuxième plus
importante de france
donc là
à temps le repaire dos ça nous fait
vingt mètres 0-2 ça a baissé de 10 cm
depuis la semaine dernière
donc c'est une descente qui est
conséquent mais il n'y a rien de
d'extraordinaire par rapport à cette
période de l'année où il ya des baisses
mais quand même on a un baisser d'un
niveau significatif
le brgm relève les niveaux de 1400
forage en france et en outre-mer
l'ensemble des mesures permet d'éditer
des bulletins précis sur l'état des
réserves d'eau souterraines
si localement de petites nappes
phréatiques ont vu leur niveau baisser
considérablement les grandes nappes
elles ne sont pas en péril les grandes
réserves qui sont principalement sur
tout le nord de la france est
effectivement non pas de stress
particulier cette année puisque ils ont
été bien remplies durant les hivers
précédents
reste que si l'automne et l'hiver à
venir ne sont pas suffisamment pluvieux
une réelle sécheresse pourrait survenir
à l'été 2016